career appreciation moment you know what
you know what a denzel washington of nfl
head coaches is
oh
it's pretty good it looks like a that's
a good transition but since he looks
like him i'm going to say the omar epps
the omar m nfl head coach
is mike tomlin
you know so those steelers win last
night over the giants no surprise right
you expected them to win but look at
some of these numbers
for for mike tomlin all right two super
bowl appearances one super bowl win
conference championship three times
six division titles
i like the regular season record one
thing i didn't see there
mike tomlin mike smith has never had a
losing season i knew you were going
there yep never
so
last year and this is where i said all
right mike tomlin
he needs to get his respect and i think
he receives respected
because people do say oh yeah he's one
of the top coaches in the league but
they don't put him up he's he should be
higher
he should be even higher he should be a
top three coach where is he should be
top three and because who does not have
him in the top three who does not and by
the way that's a tough that's a tough
club to cry because because okay because
tell me no it's not no it's not no it
isn't tough no it isn't it is a tough
death crack that is no number one is
we know number one checkers up there all
right so d reads in the comments andy
reid's in the conversation he definitely
got it
last year just right right but
i got you i'm in the conversation i'm
not this is not a definitive rank we
know one
two and three are for discussion and
nobody should
nobody should be nobody should be over
tomlin for three
name names they should not be over
timely for three name them okay but
there's a conversation that goes i agree
with you but there's a conversation that
goes beyond tomlin i think in the
conversation about these great coaches i
think you include sean payton in there i
think you include john harbaugh in there
there's there there are guys that are
you know at that round table that you
know that that's
you know so you understand what i'm
saying it's not a slam dunk but i'm with
you that tomlin is under appreciated but
i have a theory though michael i have a
theory i have a theory that you
have been in boston so long
that boston has the in the fan base in
boston in particular because they've had
belichick have also taken it as an
opportunity to disparage mike tomlin's
career because they often
i think that's no that's a fair point
and i always say this
to people when i'm talking about coaches
i say how do you know somebody is number
one now we didn't even argue over number
one why
because bill belichick has six super
bowl titles
because the patriots have won 17 of the
last 19 afc east division titles
because of his career winning percentage
so really we got hard data and i i'll
roll with the data so if if you can find
out who number one is based on the data
that's why i say mike tomlin is a clear
number two the data speaks for itself
never had a losing season as i said sean
payton somehow
has had three seven to nine seasons in
new orleans how's that possible
with drew brees anyway
uh
john harbaugh you mentioned in the same
division as mike tomlin he has had
losing seasons in that division he
hasn't doesn't have as many division
titles as tomlin so i can't play all
facts i can't put garba over tomlin in
the same division
and harbaugh doesn't come out on top of
him harbaugh doesn't have a winning
record against mike tomlin
so yeah no all facts
active coaches
second best winning percentage all time
among active coaches number one is bill
belichick number two is mike tomlin mike
tomlin so so i think the sharpest thing
is sharpest hairline
oh yeah it's tight i don't know who's
cutting them
and what's up with the pandemic though
is he getting a pandemic is he doing it
himself or
not another person again i i just just
for the record so everybody's clear i
agree with you like i said like that i
agree with you got to clap it but i'm
just i'm just showing up to some other
people you got to say i
agree
yeah pete carroll's in the mix i think
like in terms of like active coaches be
carol's problem i just want to make sure
i show love to you know show respect
pete carroll he's in there in terms of
like carol the best guys yeah but no i'm
with you
tomlin tom and i think a lot of it
honestly
so why why is mike tomlin
in some circles let's call it some
circles why is mike tomlin in some
circles
not giving his just due in pittsburgh i
think there are some people who probably
take it for granted because of the
standard that they've set in pittsburgh
or as mike would say the standard the
standard is the standard nationally i
think and you know
i think we are we both know that when it
comes to black coaches they don't get
the credit and the celebration for their
genius
they get their credit for being players
coaches
he's relatable players respond to him so
tomlin doesn't get the same way
belichick gets credit for his
organizational brilliance the structure
the hierarchy the you know the the the
just the environment that he's created
tomlin is seen as a dude that players
like
you know and you know that's it because
he's because he's one of them because he
used to play he's a black dude's brother
you know like he gets due to him as if
he got an all-black team
you know what i'm saying he's a young
guy
like you know he gets he gets through to
him you know but it's like so i think
that's typically with black coaches
equals players coaches as opposed to
savants
well one uh
credit to the steelers
for uh having a structure in place not
just with mike tomlin but having a
structure in place
that they've had three coaches in my
lifetime
like in my entire lifetime
the steelers have had three coaches
chuck noll bill cower mike thomas
done
so i like and i think this is part of
this is what a lot of coaches want but
specifically black coaches have
complained about look if you're going to
give me this job you're giving this
opportunity a lot of times i'm coming in
where i've got to reset the culture
i've got to reset the standard so to
speak to use that tomlin line
i need the time i need the time and
support to do it you can't just bring me
in in year one and say by year three
okay you didn't get it done move on
so the steelers are part of this story
they have given him what he's needed to
be successful yeah but the other thing
for tom and i think this is part of his
this is this is part of his genius
is that they are they have
they have the luxury of bringing in some
marginal
players in terms of their character
grades some guys who other teams are
maybe uncomfortable with
mike tomlin has brought them in
has allowed them to get their talent out
and then in some cases they turn around
like antonio brown was that guy
so on one hand give mike tomlin credit
because antonio guy coming out that's
receivers see that guy coming out of
college oh sure i don't think he's
actually going to was he that i got out
of college yes he was yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah some problems yeah issues okay
yeah i don't remember so sorry
on one hand on one hand give him credit
give him credit for allowing antonio
brown to become the best receiver in
steelers history
on the other hand do you go ahead and
knock him because antonio brown became a
discipline problem late in his career
yeah like well it's almost like
they knock them they knock them for the
discipline problems but don't give them
enough credit for
getting the talent out
or how long did he manage it before he
couldn't manage antonio anymore and then
we saw what happened when antonio left
but the other thing too about the
patience in pittsburgh
is some organizations with those
standards and that fan base might have
decided okay you know this has gotten
stale
mike tomlin appreciation day that's
funny guys uh that is that has gotten it
was hey it's not we monday football
otherwise non-descript other than this
um well you know is it not okay
but okay last point last point on this
is that pittsburgh could have been like
oh well eight and eight's not good
enough and let's pull the plug let's
reset let's go and try to get somebody
who can get us back over the hump and
then left the fan base and organization
longing for the days of mike tomlin
because let's face it to be accurate
that they prob as many he's his body of
work is unquestioned no losing seasons
second highest winning percentage but
there have been some seasons that have
been marred by some frustrating losses
and i'm not saying it's all mike's fault
because but i'm just saying as an
organization they've asked themselves
like how did they miss the playoffs they
are the kings of losing games they
shouldn't in a lot of seasons pass
that's right and and look you have to
i'd say you have to you have to hold
them accountable for that
but when i have these conversations with
people and say all right let's just be
consistent hold him accountable
and hold the other guys that you hold up
as as better look at some of their flaws
too
absolutely no losing seasons
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports